بتقنيه صينيه يراقب النظام الايراني
مواطنيه وفي بلد يواصل انتفاضه ضد القمع
ترصد كاميرات المراقبه الصينيه مطالبين
بالتغيير نحو مزيد من الحريات دور لبكين
في طهران رفضته الولايات المتحده التي
تدرس فرض عقوبات جديده على شركات المراقبه
الصينيه بسبب زياده مبيعاتها لقوات الامن
الايرانيه باكثر من الضعف عام 2022
وفقا لولو قد تركز العقوبات على شركه
وهي شركه لتصنيع معدات المراقبه تبيع
منتجاتها الى وحدات الحرس الثوري
ايضا لدوري شركه اخرى تدعى من خلال مشاركه
مدير مبيعاتها في مؤتمر امني نظمته الشرطه
الايرانيه الى جانب لقاءات مع رئيس جهاز
امن الدوله الايرانيه دور الشركات في
ايران قد يعرضها لعقوبات حجبها عن النظام
المالي الامريكي من قبل وزارتي الخزانه
والخارجيه الامريكيه
استخدامات كاميرات مراقبه الصينيه في
ايران يتم بالتعاون بين اجهزه الامن
والتلفزيون الرسمي الايراني من خلال
توظيفها للتعرف على وجوه المتظاهرين ومن
ثم اعتقالهم الى جانب استخدامها في اشارات
المرور لمعاقبه النساء اللائي لا يرتدين
الحجاب وفي ظل محاولات الشركات الصينيه
الالتفاف على العقوبات الامريكيه وانكار
ايران المناقض لتصريحات مسؤوليها باستخدام
كاميرات المراقبه تبقى كل من بكين وطهران
تحت مجهر امريكا والغرب الرافض لسياسات
البلدين
علي السمان العربيه